meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
ich will sie nicht länger auf die folter
spannen jetzt das ergebnis der befragung
der mitglieder der cdu deutschlands
jeder zentimeter auf den balken steht
für viele tausende mitglieder wer wird
neuer cdu vorsitzender nach befragung
der mitglieder auf helge braun entfallen
12,1 prozent auf friedrich auf norbert
röttgen fallen
25,8 prozent und auf friedrich merz
62,1 prozent der abgegebenen stimmen
das ist die absolute mehrheit
eindeutiges
ein eindeutiges ergebnis
ich will an dieser stelle sagen meine
damen und herren weil einige vorab
danach gefragt haben wie haben sich denn
welche gruppen entschieden also
diejenigen die per brief abgestimmt
haben und diejenigen die online
abgestimmt haben gab es da unterschiede
haben unterschiedliche kandidaten
gewonnen ich kann ihnen sagen heute nein
die abweichung sind sehr geringfügig und
auch in beiden verfahren sowohl bei der
briefwahl als auch bei dem online
verfahren hat friedrich merz deutlich
die absolute mehrheit erreicht lieber
friedrich merz herzlichen glückwunsch zu
diesem tollen ergebnis danke norbert
röttgen danke helge braun für ihren
einsatz
auch von meiner seite ein herzliches
glück ein herzlichen glückwunsch und der
designierte parteivorsitzende hat jetzt
das wort und wir müssen noch fragt wenn
ich das so sagen darf ob friedrich mehr
die nominierung der mitglieder an nimmt
ja vielen dank lieber polzin aktive
yvonne mag das meine damen und herren
ich bedanke mich zunächst einmal bei
allen unseren mitgliedern schon gestern
war ein guter tag für die cdu als wir
die ersten ergebnisse gehört haben was
die beteiligung ausmacht und das wir
heute bestätigt bekommen dass zwei
drittel unserer mitglieder an dieser
mitgliederbefragung teilnehmen ist ein
beeindruckendes und tolles ergebnis
einer partei die lebt und die
mitgestalten will und das ist glaube ich
ein gewinn für uns alle ich bedanke mich
war in beiden mitbewerbern mitstreitern
die wie helge braun lieber norbert
röttgen das waren herausfordernde tage
und wochen aber zwar an ein gutes
miteinander zwischen uns dreien und ich
denke das hat der partei gut getan wie
wir es gemacht haben dass wir es gemacht
haben und das hat sicherlich auch
maßstäbe gesetzt nicht nur für uns auch
für andere entscheidungen dank also
gefallen friedrich merz ist der neue cdu
vorsitzende und er hat eine große
aufgabe vor sich her und sagen wir hier
bei uns im studio diese cdu die wirklich
am boden liegt wieder neu aufzubauen
genau so ist es thomas ist ist ein
bisschen eine der ungewöhnlichsten
politiker karrieren die es vielleicht
jemals in deutschland gegeben hat denn
wir erinnern uns vor fast 20 jahren
wurde er damals von angela merkel
rausgedrängt er war fraktionschef das
hat angela merkel übernommen dann das
versucht der versuch des comebacks vor
drei jahren und dann das zweite mal
angetreten beide male verloren und jetzt
hat er es geschafft und dritten anlauf
man muss sagen seine vorgängerinnen und
vorgänger nämlich annegret kramp
karrenbauer und armin laschet hat es
nicht gepackt die cdu nach der ära
merkel in eine erfolgreiche richtung zu
führen und jetzt ist es so dass
friedrich merz die chance hat aus
rechnet er der erzfeind der kanzlerin
die cdu zu übernehmen und jetzt dann in
die opposition gehen oder short zu
bringen in dem moment wo sie weg ist sie
musste tatsächlich den weg frei machen
was für eine polit geschichte was für
ein krimi auch dass das und da würde man
jetzt gerne neben angela merkel sitzen
vielleicht ist sie in ihrem büro oder zu
hause hat den fernseher angestellt wie
die das findet das jetzt friedrich merz
ausgerechnet der mann den sie immer
verhindert hat jetzt ihre partei fühlt
und es wird spannend zu sehen sein
müssen wie ralf schuler gleich mal
fragen was sie beim parteitag macht ich
kann mir nicht vorstellen dass sie dort
in der ersten reihe sitzt ja fragen
jedoch direkt mal ralf schuler der im
konrad adenauer haus für uns vor ort ist
ralf 62% er ist noch nicht da dann
sprechen wir natürlich noch mal weiter
mit paul ein satz der mir besonders
hängen geblieben ist gerade von der rede
von friedrich merz war ich weiß was auf
mich zukommt das hört sich nicht
unbedingt nur positiv an es ist eine
riesenherausforderung die cdu die bei
der wahl hinter der spd gelandet ist die
so abgestürzt ist von den höhlen der
kanzlerin die einen erfolg nach dem
anderen eingefahren hat unabhängig davon
wie umstritten ihr kurs teilweise war
bei den mitgliedern dennoch ist es jetzt
ein klares zeichen die basis will
friedrich merz die basis wollte
friedrich mehr als sehr wahrscheinlich
schon immer auch in den vorher
vorhergegangenen entscheidungen und er
muss jetzt zeigen dass er das auch
wirklich kann man muss dazu sagen dass
ist auch einige pannen gab bei ihm in
den vergangenen jahren und er wird jetzt
beweisen müssen dass er wirklich klare
opposition machen kann und vor allem
dass er die cdu zusammen führt in einem
kurs der am ende dann erfolgreich ist
bei wahlen denn das wird das
entscheidende an aber ich glaube der
punkte nur angesprochen hast es genau
richtig er hätte er ist wahrscheinlich
schon länger gewollt worden von der
basis im nachhinein muss man ja sagen
dass annegret kramp karrenbauer die zwei
jahre nur drama als vorsitzende armin
laschet ein jahr wirken im nachhinein
sozusagen als missverständnisse
eigentlich und hier könnt ihr jetzt
einer da sein der wirklich als der
originäre
cdu-vorsitzende verstanden werden kann
friedrich merz ist definitiv und das
haben wir es schwarz auf weiß der
kandidat der basis er ist der parteichef
dann auch der basis ob er damals damit
am ende auch die breite bevölkerung
erreichen kann als volkspartei cdu bei
den nächsten wahlen denn auch wenn
natürlich landtagswahlen nicht mit ihm
direkt als person zu tun haben so wird
er doch immer wieder daran gemessen wie
erfolgreich wird die cdu hat und dann
natürlich die frage was passiert in vier
jahren bei der nächsten bundestagswahl
tritt er dann an fordert er olaf scholz
heraus oder gibt es einen erneuten kampf
wie wir ihn schon erlebt haben zwischen
dann markus söder und friedrich merz wie
sieht die spd dieses ergebnis sei
wahrscheinlich aus der spd dass man sich
freut dass im märz gewonnen hat denn man
glaubt und man traut ihnen nicht so
richtig zu dass er einen vereinenden
volkspartei kurs gegen die spd führen
kann also ich hab gestern gehört auch
wie lars klingbeil dort bei maybrit
illner friedrich merz viel glück
gewünscht hat also der neue parteichef
der spd ich glaube man hat bei der spd
ein gutes gefühl mit friedrich merz aber
wer weiß vielleicht überrascht er und
wird am ende auch in der beliebtheit in
der gesamten bevölkerung nach oben gehen
wenn er antritt dann als bundeskanzler
dann geht er auch schon leicht auf die
70 zu also er ist nicht mehr der jüngste
vielleicht ein wort auch noch zu den
unterlegenen
mitbewerbern wie es dort immer genannt
wurde helge braun norbert röttgen
norbert röttgen hat 25,8 prozent
bekommen das ist wenn ich es richtig in
erinnerung habe in etwa so viel wie er
auch vor einem jahr bekommen hat in der
abstimmung gegen armin laschet da ist
also schon ein viertel ein stabiles
viertel der parteibasis die auch ein
norbert röttgen der ja nicht so
schillernd auftritt wie friedrich merz
doch auch die gefolgschaft geben würde
das war die hoffnung von norbert röttgen
dass am ende her gebrauchen und norbert
röttgen mehr prozente haben als
friedrich merz und dann sozusagen in
einer stichwahl der vermeintlich
modernere gewinnen könnte indem mehr
prozente vom anderen bekommen das hat
nicht geklappt eine niederlage für beide
aber am ende auch das haben wir
besprochen geht es auch darum im spiel
zu bleiben irgendwie genannt zu werden
und norbert röttgen hat mit 25 prozent
einen weiteren achtungserfolg
wobei man auch da klar sagen muss
verloren ist verloren und er hat zum
zweiten mal und er sah übrigens sehr
betroffen aus also er hat seine
emotionen eigentlich fragt also indem er
da so saß und man hat ihm angesehen man
hat ihm angesehen und natürlich war die
hoffnung von norbert röttgen zumindest
in die stichwahl zu kommen denn das wäre
eigentlich wichtig gewesen norbert
röttgen ja auch jemand der nicht sicht
überworfen hat mit der kanzlerin aber
die beiden standen auch nicht fest
zusammen sie hat ihn noch als
umweltminister geschoss helge braun
wiederum jemand der also in nächster
nähe der kanzlerin stand als
kanzleramtschef nur 12,1 prozent ist das
auch zu viel merkel auch noch um ihn
herum gewesen dass helge braun überhaupt
angetreten ist war durchaus überraschen
damit hatte niemand so wirklich
gerechnet und sein image in der partei
war genau das was du angesprochen hast
er kanzleramtsminister
merkels liebster auch in der korona
politik sehr sehr eng an dem vorsichts
kurs der kanzlerin hat sich da auch
nicht nur freunde gemacht insbesondere
in der konservativen klientel von daher
dass er chancenlos werden würde war klar
aber dass norbert röttgen und er
zusammen ist nicht schaffen sozusagen
soviele prozente zu holen dass man in
einer stichwahl geht das dann doch schon
ein klarer und sichtbarer erfolg für
frieden und eine partei die lebt ist die
cdu und eine partei die lebendig ist
zweimal hat friedrich merz das betont ja
weil viele wie für halb tot erklärt
das ist richtig aber auch die spd wurde
schon mehrfach für halb tot erklärt
deswegen sollten wir da vorsichtig sein
aber was fakt ist dass man sich
zerfleischt hat in den vergangenen
jahren
dass man nicht geschafft hat nach merkel
an die erfolge anzuknüpfen man hat
keinen klaren kurs gefunden auch für den
wahlkampf natürlich sind der pannen
passiert und zur wahrheit wird auch dazu
wenn armin laschet ein prozent mehr
bekommen hätte dann wäre er heute
kanzler und wäre weiterhin
parteivorsitzender also so eng liegen
manchmal die dinge erfolg und misserfolg
beieinander
ich hatte das gefühl dass alles sehr
nach aufbruch aus nach neu anfangen und
diese ganze wahl klatsche ist eigentlich
vergessen jetzt geht es nur darum sich
wieder nur aufzustellen die einen sagen
so ich hätte ich mehr tatsächlich für
ein neu anfangen und einen aufbruch
steht da würden wahrscheinlich seine
kritiker insbesondere bei den
delegierten oder denen in dem
politischen berlin was zu sagen haben
eher ein fragezeichen hinter setzen aber
und das ist wichtig für ihn die basis
steht voll hinter ihm und die basis
insbesondere in einer situation in der
die cdu in der opposition ist hat dann
besondere macht ja schon eine wirklich
verrückte situation wenn man bedenkt
dass angela merkel die ja auch so lange
parteivorsitzende war 16 jahre kanzlerin
lang parteivorsitzende es nicht
geschafft hat ein nachfolger tatsächlich
aufzubauen der realisiert sie hat es mit
ak versucht das geht nicht und
ausgerechnet erzfeind übernimmt dann ihr
erbe sozusagen
ich wage mal zu sagen dass ihr das
vielleicht gar nicht so wichtig war
natürlich hat sie es versucht sie hat
aber auch immer gesagt am ende muss sich
diejenige oder derjenige selbst
durchsetzen muss den weg selbst finden
da kann keine vorgängerin in eine
richtung zeigen nun ist es so dass ihr
erzfeind die cdu übernommen hat
möglicherweise denkt sich die kanzlerin
ihr werdet schon noch sehen was ihr
davon habt denn wenn man sich anschaut
wie die beliebtheitswerte von friedrich
merz in der gesamtbevölkerung sind da
muss man diplomatisch sein das ist
ausbaufähig also die kanzlerin hatte
dann natürlich auch aufgrund der jahre
ganz andere werte vorzuweisen aber
friedrich merz hat jetzt die chance er
hat die chance als allen zu zeigen er
hat die chance die cdu neu aufzubauen
und er hat die chance am ende dann eine
erfolgreiche partei eine erfolgreiche
opposition zu machen und dann vielleicht
sogar kanzlerkandidat zu werden das ist
die nächste frage die sich stellen wird
wenn er denn bestätigt wird beim
parteitag ob er dann auch versucht ralph
brinkhaus zu beerben also als
fraktionschef oder ob es dann schon den
ersten machtkampf gibt also darf dann
friedrich mehr als partei- und
fraktionschef werden oder dann will hat
er ja der oppositionsführer wenn er in
der tat auch fraktionschef werden würde
vielleicht zum schluss noch ein kurzer
ausblick paul in welche richtung wird er
die partei führen wird sie mehr
von der mitte nach rechts gehen angela
merkel wurde ja oft vorgeworfen
sozusagen die
sozialdemokratisierung der cdu das klare
profil die klare kante war nicht mehr
erkennbar wird friedrich merz darin die
ja etwas rechte richtungen ich gehe
davon aus dass sich friedrich merz
insbesondere finanzpolitisch und
wirtschaftspolitisch beweisen will denn
da hat er ohne frage klare kompetenz ich
nehme an er wird auch bei der frage der
migration versuchen eine klare noch
klarere haltung zu entwickeln vielleicht
ähnlich wie sebastian kurz in österreich
um das profil insgesamt konservativer zu
machen allerdings gibt es da auch eben
die vorbehalte aus dem
arbeitnehmerflügel der union die gesagt
haben wir haben die wahl auch wegen der
sozialpolitik verloren wir müssen
antworten finden auf die themen die die
spd nach vorne gestellt hat rente
soziale sicherheit all diese dinge da
wird es einen richtungsstreit in der
union geben vielen dank wir schalten die
jetzt aber wirklich rüber zur eifel
schüler vor ort 3b wird das ergebnis bei
dir vor ort aufgenommen
also man konnte die erleichterung auf
den rängen hier im adenauer haus
geradezu mit händen greifen es gab
großen applaus von den mitarbeitern man
muss einfach sich vorstellen dass jetzt
der dritte anlauf von friedrich merz
gelungen ist es ist eine hängepartie zu
ende ging und mit einer so deutlichen
mehrheit das an der kompetenz und
autorität von friedrich merz kein
zweifel mehr bestehen kann das heißt ein
ganz klares votum das ist erstmal gut
für die partei und alle hoffen dass es
jetzt eine längere phase der stabilität
geben würde und man sollte nicht
vergessen es ist auch ein zähes ringen
mit der scheidenden kanzlerin gewesen
was am ende sich in diesem
personalentscheid
manifestiert es war angela merkel im
hintergrund die immer wieder auch ihre
truppen mobilisiert hat um friedrich
merz eben nicht ran zu lassen und man
darf gespannt sein wie das jetzt
weitergeht
ja sicherlich eine genugtuung für
friedrich merz an diesem tag das kann
man sich sicherlich aus mal vielen dank
ralf schuler für diesen letzten eindruck
noch vom konrad adenauer haus wo
friedrich merz heute zum neuen
parteivorsitzenden der cdu gewählt
worden ist im dritten anlauf hat er es
geschafft danke paul für die
einschätzung